my feeling is that China is being well
managed and the government have provided
necessary stimulus to to promote growth
within China and so I think China will
pull out all right and with regard to
the world generally it seems to me that
so the Chinese one way or the other
owed a great deal of assets which are
denominated in u.s. dollars and they
will want to protect the value of those
assets and so they will probably not
sell them and so therefore the Chinese
government as China generally speaking
will not make the recession worse but I
don't think that the growth in China
will have a great deal of direct impact
on pulling back the West essentially the
West out of the recession I think the
West will pull itself out of recession
I've got great confidence in that but so
that's my view
my overall view on this question I'm a
frequent visitor to China and I know
that China will survive very well and
will continue to prosper but I'm not
quite sure that there will have a very
direct impact on the general recession
in the West so